welcome to another episode of tiger
belly I am your Wu someone stole this
ship today why am I doing this and not
you again
I want you to try to do it what if I die
or something like I die from a new super
aids a super I go to Africa and I get a
new disease and I die okay I'm sick you
have to learn to take over I also kind
of just say this too is when you say
five four three two one you're supposed
to do some sort of weird you know okay
let's take it back wat through your fear
and you try five four three two one
little penny sits on a big coconut tree
she sits there and Ponder's her life hi
guys I am your captain over here to my
left I have Gabriel what's up Gabriel
Gabriel the house to my right the love
of my life
bow-bow bow-bow bow-bow we have Jorge in
pink
all right we have Bryce Halleck in blue
yeah he wants to [ __ ] you I think we
have good old [ __ ] eyes Bryce Halleck in
blue yeah yeah [ __ ] eyes is bent back
and we have a very very special guest
today yeah
very special cuz I feel like she's been
in our family longer than any of you
guys have been she's actually known
Bobby the longest know that everybody
welcome one of my best friends Jenna
Jimenez rape me rape me rape me that was
a [ __ ] that was good good babe that
was really good you know I liked it a
lot so if I was dying and I was
listening to that on my deathbed I'd be
like I feel like I'm not good with the
other songs though I want it I want to
redo lyric do one more time five four
three two oh I'm just gonna do a nips
commercial okay want me to like beatbox
for you I cannot do that
you can't talk yeah I'm supposed to say
that excuse me Jenna you're not supposed
to talk until I say you can talk listen
to your [ __ ] yeah I don't want to hear
your voice until I am done introducing
you okay
that I'd do that right yeah okay kind of
hard right now man it's like when I when
I hear me I get [ __ ] turned on
half-chub he always he doesn't allow
people to talk tell them the rule yeah
everything there's a deal here's the
deal okay is is that it's weird when
people don't know who the guest is and
if they start talking beforehand you
gotta have the proper introduction
that's why I do it that way all right
I think the song that you did in the
beginning was really cute and I liked it
a lot he can go a little weird or maybe
some more like so let's try something
different
5/4 under words 5 4 3 2 1
the crocodile is a form of a reptile an
alligator is that he doesn't have salt
ducks yeah
Salta oh that's my if I ever have
another podcast that's the salt dog no
he has salt ducks the alligator doesn't
I [ __ ] it up it's okay baby just move
on
just shut up George everybody Jenna
[Music]